so we'd like to open up the questioning
now to all the members of the panel so
feel free to ask whatever questions from
any one of us here yes peace I actually
so I have two questions one of them is
about snowfall but it's more about the
kind of reporting process this is
mentioned in the introduction to a
snowfall a little he a few minutes ago
but one thing that really struck me is a
reader was how well the interpersonal
relationships were captured in the piece
and so I was wondering if you could
speak a little bit to how you capture
that element of the story which ended up
being very important to what happened to
the skiers my second question is for
insideclimate watch um I'm curious about
yo Suh as a small publication and with
the attention you've gotten from this
prize um how your I'm kind of curious
about how your funding and advertising
processes work especially when we were
just speaking about that on the level of
the New York Times so those are my two
question okay should we take the second
question first to give these guys some
rest so how has your life changed since
the Pulitzer Prize cuz we're totally
foundation driven so advertising wasn't
on the table I think maybe years ago
before either of us were involved they
may be took some ads but they decided
against that the the goal is for a prize
like this and the others that we've won
through this is to get more people on
staff so that we can actually have more
than two people or keep that special
project and maybe bring in some
multimedia so our staff is growing and
using something like this is you know
it's a tool to get more foundations but
our publisher really takes care of that
I mean we don't that we have that
firewall between us and we just explain
what we're funded by foundations but
that we hope will grow
also with the economy may be recovering
that will help our cause to so you're
going from four to seven people now
right we have eight now oh yeah maybe no
wonder in the service area that's great
and the other question about real
quickly and I think we could probably
all agree on this for the most part
these aren't stories about things these
are stories about people and at the
heart of any great story is the personal
relationships and what's you know it's a
story about humanity so I think it was
very important and you know I'd like to
think that the relationships that I've
built with the people who were willing
to open up and kind of reopen these
wounds and so on sort of lent some
authenticity to it and yeah I think
that's the key I mean it's I don't no
offense I don't want to read a story to
spot avalanches but it's the people
involved and make it interesting yes
peace going on interpersonal
relationships what struck me is a
sensitivity that you took with this
graphic material and I'm wondering what
your balance was between I want to
inform the audience of what happened but
at the same time I don't want to be too
graphic and secondly were you ever
concerned that the visuals would
interfere with the sensitivity that you
had established with the people you were
interviewing second part no because I
was somewhat involved I have no idea how
they did it but somewhat involved in
sort of looking over their shoulder and
being a part of it so I kind of knew all
along it was going on you know just like
you guys probably but this is probably
four months before the story ran I got
an email the drop box with that flyover
I was in my backyard in California on my
laptop and I opened up and was like holy
cow you know okay I can see where this
is going this is going to be really cool
and so I was vested in you I fully
believe in Steven his team and and
wasn't worried about that at all it was
a huge supplement it hugely helped
telling the story the sensitivity issue
is an interesting one when I talk to the
people i mean i really believe as a
reporter that the thing you do first is
explain to people that this is going to
be honest and full and accurate
portrayal of what happened can't promise
are going to like it they may not like
you they may wish they'd ever talk to
you
but you're going to go into this in and
be as honest up front as possible they
eventually opened up and told me some of
the gory details and I knew some of
those gory details were probably going
to affect some of the people who lost
loved ones and sure enough I got emails
and calls from some of them afterward
saying it was really really hard to read
but thank you because now I know
truthfully you have to remember you're
not writing this for them your readiness
for readers so it has to be accurate you
can't really censor things I'll give you
a quick anecdote I did get I did give a
heads up to somebody at stevens pass
saying we I have decided we're going to
use one of 911 calls and I want to give
you a heads-up because I think it's
really sensitive and it's a 911 call
that was placed actually it's not the
one calling the ski patrol office if any
of you happen to click on it telling
them we have the names of the people who
have died and here they are and at the
time the ski patrol office thought it
was just another avalanche the
backcountry didn't realize the people
who had died poor good friends of theirs
and the 911 call is you know she's very
nonchalantly to tell for the names and
you hear the woman whale and it moves me
just thinking about it I got a call
about two days before we published from
the woman saying please don't put that
in here and I explained to her and nice
long conversation explain to you why I
thought it was important that it shows
the emotion her name also was not
attached to it so nobody can really
figure out who she is but I told her I
thought for the for the broader story it
was important that it be in there that
was a tough conversation to have when
somebody's begging you take something
out of the story we should ask sadly
this question as well I mean you talk to
you have to develop sources in the
course of doing this story and as well
as other stories how do you how do you
get people to open up to you you know it
really depends on on the topic and and
how you reach out to people we just
recently finished an eight month
investigation on sex predators that the
state had a chance to lock up and
and under civil commitment and did not
and then they went out and did horrible
things again and I you know in that case
that's a very sensitive thing especially
with rape victims who we had to approach
and you know I would explain to them
that I'm interested in your story but
we're looking we're taking a much larger
look at this and there's a systemic
problem in the state that have allowed
people like the your attacker to you
know to commit horrible crimes and I
hope that you'll consider talking to me
because your story could really make a
difference on a much bigger scale and
that that seems to work so I think it
kind of depends on on the topic but some
people you know that just don't want to
talk to you there's not much you can do
but it's and then others you can sort of
compel into it even if they hang up on
you the first two or three times so John
the Floyd's your main character he was
sort of a willing very willing source
right but were there problems in that
relationship in terms of his
expectations for example of what the
story is good no he pretty much gave me
you know complete trust there were there
were other people who were you know some
neighbors who were less willing to talk
in those circumstances sometimes it's
just a matter of time and sometimes if
you send them work that you've done they
can read it and feel comfortable that
you are you know particularly when
you're inside climate News which a lot
of people haven't heard of they want to
know some background and so I'm happy to
give them anything they need but it's
and then it's some it's the listening I
mean we can't report if we don't listen
we can't we have to let people tell
their story it's very it's cathartic
it's whatever but that our ears are
really really our most important tools
thank you yes this egg I that's more for
the Sun Sentinel and insert climate news
how do you maintain a relationship to
your target like you're going into this
area and you have all these people and
with oil in the lawns and then you have
the big oil company and you said you
still like talk to Jason
the PR guy after five months and how to
use their neutral and not like going on
to one side and reporting against the
other one yeah I guess it's interesting
because it's it's like a lot of things
you you hear one side and you think well
you know they have a valid point then
you hear the other side me their number
two sides they're always 25 sides and
you think well haven't they have a
really good point too okay I'm still in
the middle I'm a moderate so it's it's
I'm not I'm not interested in their
agenda and a lot of people have agenda
sometimes not John the forge but certain
people were obsessed with well there's a
little tiny bit of oil over here and you
have to we have to get rid of that and
you you can't listen to people's axe
grinding well you listen to it but you
have to filter it out because you have
to keep yourself on your telling the
story for an audience and if we don't
have readers or lost as reporters
because if no one's listening to you
because they don't trust you as a as a
journalist then you're sunk so it but it
is I'm sure journalists do get sucked
into things that's why it's so important
to keep checking it out you know I mean
I I went to the University of Missouri
in Columbia for the journalism school I
still hear that professor of mine say
you make that one more phone call
because it's you're tired it's the end
of the day you want to go but you make
that one more phone call you send that
one more email because that you just you
need to keep verifying these things and
and that's why editors are valuable to
keep you on that track so if you start
to waver or go you know you're too
involved this one thing you need another
voice to keep you honest yes peace I
have a question for John and Steve I was
wondering what the range of reader
reactions was to the story and if it
gave you any new insight and to reader
demand and interest when it comes to
long form and what they want you
responded to a lot of the readers issue
yeah it was it was actually very strange
at first and I don't know if any of you
have read the comments but they
were glowing I mean I was unbelievable
because there's always some cranks I
mean every story and this one was like
strangely glowing and I was kind of
freaked out by that and now I know it
pretty quickly turned I think at least
within the business like the anti
snowfall like we're so aren't you guys
tired snowfall every quit talking about
this and so there was like this sort of
spun back the other way the readers I
think you know the greatest compliment
you can get is somebody saying I read
seventeen thousand words thank you Steve
for helping them do that because I don't
know how to coupon she read it but it
was easier to get through I'm very
pleased with the readers you know you
die said you write this for the readers
and you're never going to make everybody
happy but I think for the most part
people were dazzled and I think they are
beyond being dazzled I think there was a
more of a quorum ocean there of touched
I'll just jump in a you know the only I
think the feedback that we got that was
most meaningful was where readers were
maybe cautioning us about what they
perceived as kind of a lack of
discipline just about the overall size
of the project which i didn't really
feel that way about it but it's
certainly something that is in the back
of our minds as we produce longer pieces
now is really just how much can readers
what should the total length of the
project be what kind of investment can
we expect readers to make in it and
thinking about how we're editing
different you know pieces with that in
mind so that it so that it is a
reasonable experience if I can do a 30
second ad on to that because I there
were certainly a lot of readers who said
it's an avalanche three people died
right why not do this about poverty well
not do this about war well Steve alluded
to a couple of reasons one an avalanche
it was a contained thing it was a one
narrative I'm not sure how you construct
this on a war or poverty or something
there's one kind of containable thing
there was not a huge deadline pressure
and I just think sort of it there was a
little bit of serendipity in terms of
where we were
culturally as a newspaper with long form
where we were culturally with expanding
our horizons with multimedia and I just
think it was kind of a perfect story at
the perfect time in some ways and so we
did it sorry if it made some people mad
that we it just sort of worked out that
way thank you yes this is for John but
it also applies to pretty much everybody
else you said you have a document that's
30,000 words how do you go through that
and pick out the most important things
that are going to end up in the peace
making sure that you get what you need
for the narrative but also being sure
not to leave out anything that's
important yeah in hindsight that
document was probably I mean it was sort
of the basis of everything you know once
i had at karna logically you could sort
of go through and you sort of see who
says this best you know the hardest part
of any story i guess is what to leave
out when you have seventeen thousand
words of people would say you didn't
leave anything out dude it wasn't it
wasn't that hard but they're what I will
tell you probably hardest part was early
on I thought I need to tell the story
through five or six or seven people
because it's going to be too convoluted
with 16 characters and where I think
multimedia helped is that I said really
we're going to be able to like show
where they came down the mountain really
we're going out mug shots I wonder if I
can get away with the audacity of having
16 people and get all their voices in it
so part of that d structuring of my
notes was I want to get everybody
involved who was part of this story I
leaned a lot on them because i thought
you know as much as i'd like to think i
can have readers keep track of 16
characters in a story that i know it's
not true but thanks to multimedia that
was one crutch i was given so how do you
how do you guys cut down on you in any
major investigation any you know effort
that takes more than a couple of weeks
you amass a lot of information how do
you organize and cut it down yeah I mean
ours was the same thing it was this
chronology that we were trying to build
and we were focusing on the first
three days the first week after this
spill and then carrying it through and
sometimes material is just it's
repetitive or it's too dull or you
absolutely can't verify it so you have
to find another way to tell it but it's
some it's difficult I mean because you
have so much material and but you have
to think about the reader and you know
it can be painful and an editor says
when you've worked on this thing for I
don't know how many hours and then they
say well we're just going to take that
out we signs you can't fight if it's
worth fighting for you fight for it
don't ever let an editor tell you
something isn't worth fighting for you
need to do that but sometimes you have
to compromise and you have to just say
you're right it's too much it's a it's a
roadblock so Sally yeah i think you know
it's pretty typical for an investigation
to end up using you know ten percent of
all of the material that you that you
gather and and your story evolves in the
course of many months and you just have
to be very selective i think as you go
along sometimes you'll you'll go down to
take a right turn and end up reporting
out something that really isn't it's a
tangent it's not something that's it's
going to carry the story forward and you
just sort of dispense with that keep
very organized notes and files on on
everything and just really always think
about what is the most compelling thing
that's going to advance the story your
most compelling examples and and self
edit and then have we have great editing
staff that comes along and does what we
call gut checks all the way up through
the the final editing of you know are we
are we on the right track and always
anticipate what the other side how read
it from the other side whoever that is
it is if it's the cops or you know
whoever the other side is what how are
they going to view this and and what can
you do to protect yourself and and be as
fair and balanced as possible yes kitty
I have a question for John lines and
Lisa song in terms of using data and
you're reporting myself and a couple of
other classmates this week I've actually
been discussing just how much of skilled
you actually need to call yourself a
data reporter and what's essential in
the newsroom a lot of people are
learning things like Excel and SQL but
people are going further and learning
things like Python how far do you want
to push the limits well I always tell
our reporters that I want to I know
there are things that I do that they
can't do and frankly don't want to do
and and but I always tell the reporters
everybody every Porter should know Excel
least the basics and and most of us who
have been in this business in the data
end as long as i have taught ourselves
there was no training at j schools
really are not that much so you
basically learn what you want to learn
like in and and if you want to learn
more and go on to python fine but if not
fine and one thing I it's kind of
interesting to hear John and Steve talk
about you know we're at the cusp there's
something new here maybe and 10 years
from now it'll be a cinch to do what
they did was snowfall well we cross that
bit of that barrier on the data in about
15 years ago because that's when
computers became powerful enough that we
could actually do the data work now
we're just getting near that and there
with multimedia now you know 15 years
ago you couldn't do any of this stuff up
here I said I think I'm not a data
expert at all i did was go to a one-week
boot camp but it was enough for what we
had to do and i think the really
valuable things you learn there are
obviously the excel and access and a
little bit of sequel but most
importantly you learn to think of how to
use data and you learn to look for
places where you can get spreadsheets
you learn how to ask for them in
whatever format and once i get it even
if i can't analyze it I know what I know
what's possible and so right now
insideclimate is collaborating with the
center for public integrity
a project and they have an actual data
expert so sometimes what will happen is
I'll say okay we need to scrape this
data and take X Y or Z out of it I don't
know how to do it but I know it's
possible and then I'm able to
communicate with their data person and
they do the magic so that is always
helpful sorry I know we're tight on time
I just had a question for John branch as
well obviously in the reporting you went
really deep with your your sources but
i'm wondering i mean in terms of
retaining control over your narrative
it's it's a question that a lot of
people have asked you mentioned that you
wrote it up in a chronological format is
that something that you find to be the
most effective technique for retaining
control of your narrative it's running
to 30,000 words unfortunately most of my
stuff is not 30,000 words or seventeen
thousand words in this case I thought it
was useful I'm weirdly proud of the fact
that not only is a long story but if I'm
sure as to the longest story The Times
has ever run without a nut graph and it
wasn't really by design but as I started
to write it we slowly realized as we're
getting like other people to start
reading it within the newsroom like the
suspense that was built into it and so
it was after it was all written and I
kind of went back and said you know I
don't want to try to create us like some
sort of suspense thriller but it makes
sense chronologically and you don't
really know who lives and who dies until
the end I didn't to make that a cheap
trick but it turned out that way and it
was interesting when it first came out I
was getting emails from people who saw
this and the very first thing you see it
deletes talking but I got several emails
from people saying it's killing me you
got to tell me does at least live
she's on the video yeah this question is
for Elizabeth and Lisa and it's probably
a better question for your like your
publishers but they're not here so you
mentioned that your syndicating some of
your your stories with Bloomberg and you
know the New York Times recently you
know closed its environment desk and I
was wondering um just from like a
business perspective in terms of way to
fund this has there been any discussion
of like allowing news or allowing papers
to kind of outsourced their environment
reporting to you guys maybe you just
started that conversation because it's I
mean there are more partnerships going
on because that's how we're that's how
we can grow our staff for particular
projects it doesn't mean it's a
permanent thing but looking for these
these places where we can match but it
totally makes sense now because now that
we have some more credibility and we can
have conversations with people who know
who we are and know what we can do but
that that's a very valid suggestion and
it and it's going to happen more and
more and more with the way things are
shrinking certain things are shrinking
other things are growing so it's it's
going to constantly be fluid i think so
i'm looking at all your faces and you
seem not to want this to end but we must
end so i'd like to thank you all very
much for the very good questions that
you've asked and of course our panelists
willing to answer that question I wanna
echo the thanks that Sheila just spread
and I think a couple of things going on
up here tonight one you really see the
reconfiguration of journalism in America
and you can also see despite the
hand-wringing you encounter that we in
many ways there in the Golden Age of
storytelling because of all the tools
that are available today the other thing
is I said you'd find out a bit on how
you win a Pulitzer Prize and I think
they they demonstrated that very well
tonight so give a nice round of applause
thank you all for coming